salut tout le monde on est d'un retour
et cette fois ci ce sera pas une partie
de philidor mais un peu les
contributions qu'il a pu faire dans des
finales alors on commence avec cette
finale en trois tours pions contre roye
tour et l'a montré la méthode la plus
simple pour faire nul
j'espère que vous connaissez son appel
la position de philidor en fait
d'ailleurs qui porte son nom vous pour
la retrouver dans tous les manuels de
final très classique
ok qu'est ce qui nous a dit fier d'ars
et que donc là vous aviez noire des
bleus comme qui défend pour pour faire
annuler la méthode la plus simple c'est
d'amener le roi donc le roi défensif
face aux pions dont l'arrivée sur la
case de promotion très bien et de couper
le roi adverse ici sa sixième rang j'ai
donc on fait ça pourquoi parce que on
veut le bloquer donc on veut pas que les
blancs puissent progresser a mené droit
pourquoi ça si ici on joue un coup bas
vont faire un tour c'est 8
qu'est ce qui se passe mal et blanc vous
faire re f6 bon alors imaginons qu'on
fasse va trop rien fait on n'a pas grand
chose à faire
comme parent tour à 8
à ce moment là les blancs vont passer
l'autre côté du tour h7 et vous faire sa
com l'audace et on n'aura pas le temps
de faire un échec latéral puisque y aura
simplement le kulo six blocs le pion
vous prendrez case de fuite deux ou
trois le roi ici vous dans un réseau de
maths et thouars la c1 trois problèmes
du coup ce truc à faire serait dansant
avec le roi mais maintenant on va
simplement
tous ses pions adam et voilà et les
logan donc on comprend qu en rien sa
marche pas et du coup donc l'idée de
philidor de mettre la torah 6 très forte
donc donc on empêche le plan des blancs
de monter donc là les blancs s'y passe
ils font des échecs qui font rien ou
tourner en rond et aucun problème vous
rester en place
s'ils font un coup comme ça coût neutre
bah vous pouvez ne rien faire comme ça
les gars plein de coups peut rien faire
mais un truc très bien et va les
entendre et du coup le seul plan que les
blancs peut vouloir mener à bien ses
deux pouces et aux six en disant voilà
je bloque la tour du coup je vais de mon
roi ici et c'est bon je refais ce que je
voulais avec mon roi bon piont je lui
prends les cases devant jeu le menace de
l'at il va défendre d'un côté je passe
de l'autre avec ma tour et je l'achève
là bas le truc c'est que là bas c'est à
vous de jeu avec les noirs
maintenant que l'option là vous pouvez
passer de l'autre côté retour sur la
première et met d échec par derrière
maintenant que le pion ici le rendra
plus d'abris terrain jusqu'à présent
évité la joue aux échecs il pouvait
venir ici
maintenant tout ça c'est fini du coup je
sais pas les blancs font un peu comme ça
moi ils menacent maths mais échec
il vous fait des chèques tout le temps
voyez je n'en avais pas trop s'enfuir si
le roi vient trop proche de retour c'est
dire qu'ils trop loin de 100 kg on
pouvait simplement attaqué le pion et
puis vous avez le reprendre s'il défend
fait recette et tour trempions au
suivant et c'est dans la poche et c'est
nul voila bon ça c'est ce qu'on appelle
la position de philidor dans les finales
de tours et donc il expliqué cette
méthode de défense très simple mais mais
très efficace tout raciste à noter que
si jamais vous étiez déjà comme ça par
exemple et semblant de jouer ça serait
quand même pas perdu vous pouvez quand
même perdu en 3 et 6 alors surtout vous
ne faites pas ça maintenant on l'a déjà
dit ça ça gagne mais on peut faire tout
récent échec ou tour un pas important
vers turin
voilà et là le truc à savoir s'il faut
partir petit côté nohra par petit côté
quand vous êtes attaqué on est là du
coup j'ai blanc peuvent tenter d'essayer
d'avancer le pion comme ça tout à petit
mais l'internet parti petit côté que le
roi qui vous gardez le grand côté pour
la tour je voulais revenir faire des
échecs et et ça c'est nul mais ok ça
c'est déjà plus philidor on n'est pas la
fin des cours sur les finales je suis là
pour parler du joueur français et donc
la contribution philidor c'était ce tour
à 6 voilà si vous avez sept points de
cette opportunité c'est là sachez faire
mieux comme ça ça vous aura des demi
point voilà allez on se retrouve
maintenant pour une autre position de
phildar bientôt plus compliqué et
et sur l'enfant chez adobe je vous
laisse à bientôt